for more than two decades cops has
provided American families with
something to watch on Saturday nights
it's also opened a window into the work
of various local law enforcement
agencies the craziness we see on the air
is just what goes on in front of the
camera so here are just a few things
that have gone on behind the scenes
cops exists because of a writer strike
in researching his 1983 film cocaine
blues cops co-creator John Langley went
on ride-alongs to a couple of drug busts
his experience gave him the idea for
cops
Langley also worked on the Geraldo
Rivera hosted poorly received American
Vice the doping of a nation despite the
unfortunate association with Geraldo
Langley was able to come up with a
winning idea at the same time Hollywood
was suffering through a Writers Guild of
America strike and networks had a need
for unscripted programming this perfect
storm birthed cops and American
television has never been the same some
cities refused to allow filming because
police officers conduct serious work
cops film crews can't randomly show up
at any precinct and just start filming
after all having a camera crew following
you around all night can be annoying as
well as dangerous Langly fought through
this initial reluctance in order to get
his show on the air legend when we
started cops nobody wanted to be on top
including the cops I mean it was a very
bold idea the film crews need to get
permission and not all precincts comply
both Honolulu and Chicago have refused
to allow filming in their cities even
after multiple requests the reason for
the refusal is that police work is not
entertainment and cops trivializes
policing according to the Chicago Police
Department producers have been accused
of breaking the rules cops made an
entire episode out of the arrest of
Dalia Dippolito who was caught trying to
hire a hitman to murder her husband the
TV series was filming in the area when
the local PD sting operation went down
and cops got Dippolito signature on a
release form so they could air her
arrest dipa leo claims the release form
was misrepresented to her which the
police did not deny
the little lie didn't affect the jury
who still found her guilty she was
originally sentenced to 20 years in
prison but her conviction was reversed
in 2014
Dippolito is currently awaiting retrial
maybe cops can film a sequel episode
police accidentally killed a crew member
with all the danger of filming cops it's
not completely surprising that someone
has been killed during production in
August of 2014
police accidentally shot and killed
sound engineer Bryce Dion the incident
began when a pellet gun wielding suspect
pointed his weapon at a Wendy's employee
and the police opened fire police killed
the suspect along with Dion who was hit
by friendly fire while police claimed a
suspect opened fire on them the suspects
family claimed the officers were just
excited to be filmed and the tragic
incident resulted from them showing off
for the cameras Burt Lancaster was
involved before the folks at Fox felt
cops was just about ready to go they
decided it needed one more thing
starpower so in 1989 who was the biggest
star they could get Tom Cruise Michael
Keaton Patrick Swayze nope instead
Golden Age Hollywood handsome guy Burt
Lancaster alone his vocal talents to the
show the From Here to Eternity star
delivered the opening disclaimer for the
1989 pilot episode and that was it cops
is about real people and real crime it
was filmed entirely on location with the
men and women who work in law
enforcement there's no word on how much
it cost to hire Lancaster who hadn't had
a major role in almost a decade
but seeing us how they used his voice
just once let's hope for Fox's sake it
wasn't a lot of money it triumphed over
cancellation after over two decades as
one of Fox's go-to hits the network
pulled the plug on cops but fans of the
boys in blue didn't have to worry spike
TV soon picked up the show now cops can
be viewed alongside such dynamic fare as
ink master Bellator MMA and lip sync
battle
things have never looked better for
American law enforcement officers ends
heck America thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what you think of cops